so somebody has symptoms but they need
to be tested and we're trying to arrange
testing but testing is lagging just a
little bit
[Music]
Chicago is seeing a spike in coronavirus
infections among its most vulnerable
communities that includes the estimated
86,000 people experiencing homelessness
dr. Thomas Huggett a physician at
Lawndale Christian Health Center is
heading a medical team that is targeting
homeless people over the age of 60 or 55
if they have underlying medical
conditions forget three meals a day
delivered to you we will deliver your
medicines to you our hope is we'll also
be doing is when you go you will also be
tested for the corona virus sometimes
it's hard to get testing right but we
will have testing for you tests show the
rate of infection in homeless shelters
can run as high as forty percent
according to doctor Hagen
my job today is to ease that warm
handoff transition from staying in the
shelter to going into the hotel in order
to ease crowding in shelters and allow
cope with 19 patients to isolate the
city has set up a series of temporary
shelters in large field houses around
the city and two hotels on this day dr.
Huggett is checking on patients in a
converted boutique hotel he's not only
treating patients at the hotel he's also
sleeping their security called me about
12:30 that someone's been smoking the
elevator and they there were was the
prescription bottle they were so this is
our operation center on the second floor
here of the hotel so this central areas
where we receive phone calls from
patients kind of you could almost think
of it like a hotel front desk we have 86
people in the hotel this morning all of
these are coming from congregate shelter
sites large shelter sites that where
there isn't that a safe place for people
who are at high risk all right hi mr.
Hall is the dr. heckett with the team
okay you can come to the door with your
mascot oh great
how you doing okay let's put that into
your tongue you just pull that up there
no you don't don't touch don't touch me
let's check your oxygen level there it
is 98% and 67 is your pulse those are
normal mr. Hall those are perfect any
cloth any shortness of breath yeah each
of us has to find out what our
contribution is you know we have to help
our brothers and sisters I understand
risks and these are not routine
this is the first time that I've been
anxious in years I'm not anxious about
scabies and bedbugs and TB and anything
else but it actually made me a little
anxious in 30 years of working in
homeless shelters never had this level
of anxiety among the patients just that
uncertainty and they're in a shelter and
some of them have been homeless for many
years and you would think while coming
to a hotel is going to be positive but
you're taking them out of the comfort
zone even though it's dysfunctional it's
still what they know so you amp up the
anxiety about coming somewhere new on
top of it and got tested negative I am -
I really am no I want to tell you a
couple things but there have been some
false negatives of course
[Music]
you may get tested again
and maybe want to do some even some
blood testing because there are new
tests that come all the time right no
we'll keep on fighting that's what our
team is doing you know our team is
working hard know
so we'll keep on fighting we wouldn't be
this where I've been won fit it and
we'll keep on fighting for you yes right
thank you thank you very much